Hey guys I'm Grant Thompson with www.thekingofrandom.com
I just saw this video from Destin with Smarter Every Day
about him punching a guy in the stomach at about
3200 frames a second which looked awesome,
and I thought that would be a cool experiment to duplicate,
so ...
... I went and got this guy.  This is Darren Dyk with BeyondSlowMotion.
And I went and got this guy ...
... This is my good friend Jeremy Hardie.  Make a muscle.
So I think with a little bit of slow motion camera
and good friends, maybe we can duplicate that experience
"King of Random" style.  Let's check it out.
3 .. 2 .. 1
Hiya
Hadouken
Yes!
Well guys, I really hope you enjoyed that.  We had a  lot of fun doing it.
Shout-out to Destin from Smarter Every Day for the idea,
and what's really weird about this, is I just realized,
I'm actually wearing the same shirt that Destin was wearing in the video.
And that wasn't planned at all.  It's kind of crazy.
So thanks to Darren Dyk from BeyondSlowMotion.  Make sure you check out his channel.
He actually let me slap him in the face with a fist full of fire
so if you want to see that, make sure you check out the video right here.
And thanks to my friend Jeremy Hardie.
He dropped everything tonight just to stop by and make this all possible.
If you want him for anything, and ladies he is single,
contact me and I'll get you in touch.
Hey, thanks for watching, we'll see you around.
3 .. 2 .. 1
Hadouken
Dang it.  Missed